there you are it's time to get up and go
bargain hunting games stop the retailer
with the name that's incredibly close to
our own is holding their pre Black
Friday sales event and it starts today
I'm Lucy and welcome to this bargain bin
gamespot news update so from today the
retailer will offer PlayStation 4
hardware bundles with various extras and
50% of a variety of games one of the
doorbuster deals are no I have no idea
what that means either
good for today and tomorrow only is the
call of duty black ops 3 ps4 bundle with
a free copy of destiny the taken King
legendary edition that's the one with
all of the stuff if you were wondering
if you buy the Star Wars Battlefront ps4
system you can also get a free console
carry a backpack other offers include
the ps4 camera for $30 which you can use
with until dawn if you choose to pick
that up also for 30 bucks Dark Souls 2
is also available for $20 and for the
collectors among you Game Stop is also
offering a buy two get three free deal
on select disney infinity and Skylanders
toys so make sure you're the popular one
this Christmas games stop will be closed
on Thanksgiving Day November 26th but
will open its doors early on Black
Friday some of the retailers Black
Friday actual deals include $300 ps4 and
Xbox one bundles and more so there's
some great bargains for you to pick up
this holiday week for more deals be sure
to check out GameSpot comm where we've
collected all the best savings from
Amazon Costco and more don't forget i'm
on twitter at Lucy James games and I'll
see you next time for another G s news
update